nous sommes au la chine samovar en plein
coeur de manhattan
une institution depuis 1986 où se
retrouvent exilés russes ukrainiens
ouzbeks quand ils ont le mal du pays
mais depuis la guerre le restaurant a vu
son chiffre d'affaires chuter les
affaires reprennent tranquillement
quand la guerre a commencé nos affaires
ont chuté de 60 à 70% de richard on a
perdu beaucoup de clients sans compter
le harcèlement qu'on subit depuis le 24
février
pip autochtones les gens donner des
coups de pied sur la porte
on reçoit toujours des messages de haine
on nous traite de fasciste et donné 10
alors qu'on est dedans
tubing
depuis ils arborent le drapeau ukrainien
et multiplier les levées de fonds pour
les réfugiés en face le ratio vodka rhum
a reçu le même traitement
comment on a changé dans votre cas russe
pour de la vodka canadienne dit il
nicolaï et le gérant est lui aussi sait
faire seul et
je parlais russe avec mon ami dit-il on
me demandait pourquoi je suis ici
d'arrêter la guerre le ton était
agressive en quatre lots et agressif
[Musique]
just obligaire j'ai quitté la russie
parce que c'est dangereux d'être gay dit
il on n'a rien à voir avec cette guerre
on appelle ce coin de new york les tôles
odessa c'est à brighton beach à une
heure de manhattan
katia est venu profiter du beau temps
avec sa mère qui est arrivé du
bélarussien
on s'entretue dit elle on a de la
parenté dans toute l'europe de l'est on
a de la famille en ukraine est
impossible d'envoyer de l'argent au
bélarus pour aider ces familles dont
vaste une réunion sur le sida star voici
nyonié n'a arrêté son service du talent
on ne peut rien envoyer leur situation
va se détériorer
la station freedom fm est la seule qui
diffuse en russe à new york et miami
comme chaque tome de prost
je suis déprimé choquée j'ai honte dit
michael novak off je me sens mal pour
les ukrainiens et les russes ce n'est
pas le peuple qui a commencé la guerre
c'est poutine et de roches ou des pop
stars de
cette guerre aurait pu être évitée dit
michael les victimes white marder
pistons lits actuellement des
pourparlers de paix dit il que l'ukraine
soit neutre démilitarisé et qu'elle ne
fasse pas partie de l'otan ce sont les
mêmes demandes qu'avant la guerre et
zelensky considère cette possibilité
comme ça
même les enfants leur point de vue
d'abord
cette guerre n'aurait jamais dû se
produire
moitié russe et ukrainien il incarne
peut-être à lui tout seul l'espoir de ce
peuple déchiré
[Musique]
issia zeppo déguise radio-canada new
york